qu'est-ce que tu as amené là c'est pour
Patrick Sébastien et qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dedans du tabac puis du papier ah du
papier et du tabac voilà très bien merci
voilà très bien comme ça P pouvoir
rouler tes cigarettes mais j'espère que
c'est vraiment du tabac sinon c'est un
très gros cadeau qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire toi quand tu seras un grand garçon
raconteur d'histoire tu veux que je t'en
raconte une ouais vas-y tu sais qui
est-ce qui a inventé la danse des
canards non président mitéran pourquoi
parce qu'il a dit fermez vos goulf que
tu veux vous RRE on vous
allier monsieur le Président comprendra
n'est-ce
pas monsieur Sébastien il circule dans
les écoles ah il tire ça et dans la
nouvelle génération
alors c'est encore maléger en honneur
qui fiche le GAMP pour cette année